éric bocquet sénateurs pcf du nord
[Musique]
bonjour eric bocquet merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
dunkerque donc confiné ce week-end à
partir de demain après le littoral des
alpes-maritimes on s'attend à des
mesures similaires pour une dizaine de
départements si ce n'est pas pour toute
la france on verra bien ce que dit jean
castex aujourd'hui que pensez vous de
ces nouvelles restrictions
bah écoutez elle était demandé par les
élus du territoire concerné depuis
depuis deux semaines déjà
donc on a perdu un peu de temps je pense
d'ailleurs ça a été dit lors de la
réunion les chances qui a eu hier avec
olivier ferrand madame bourguignon avec
les les élus locaux les élus du
territoire et les autorités de santé
notamment
donc cette mesure était attendue mais
par ailleurs les je pense que les élus
s'en sortit un peu frustré de cette
rencontre parce que il ya évidemment le
confinement qu'il fallait décider je
pense c'est ce que les élus demandaient
comme mesures efficaces et puis après
est venu bien sûr la question des
vaccins dont l'approvisionnement
évidemment est notoirement insuffisant
sur le territoire comme ailleurs en
france alors les vaccins on va en parler
dunkerque confiner le week-end à partir
de demain la ville qui va recevoir vous
venez de le dire des vaccins
supplémentaires pas suffisamment selon
vous voyez ce qu'on a dit justement
patrick kanner votre confrère du nord
qui dénonce lui des décisions à
retardement
il avait d'ailleurs demandé des
précisions sur les doses disponibles en
vain écoutez je n'ai toujours pas de
réponse à ma lettre
on a l'impression que c'est toujours dos
au mur que l'on reçoit les vaccins là
avec cette situation peut en espérer
quelques dents en plus mais c'est
toujours quand il ya le feu qu'on ramène
les seaux d'eau n'est pas quand il ya
des flammèches consorts les extincteurs
pourquoi ne pas commencer à travailler
sur l'île de france dès aujourd'hui je
n'arrive pas à comprendre il faut
arrêter de prendre les français pour des
buses pour vous on n'anticipe pas
suffisamment vous êtes d'accord avec
patrick kanner je partage cette analyse
effectivement l'annoncent
qu'on dit spectaculaire de 16000 vaccins
supplémentaires sur un territoire qui
représente environ 100000 habitants
16000 ça permettrait de vacciner 8000
personnes
et par ailleurs il y avait aussi des
représentants de la communauté de
communes des hauts de flandre qui à
l'arrière de du pays dunkerquois qui
représente 55 mille habitants et dont le
président a annoncé que 4 450 personnes
avaient pu être vaccinés soit 0 87% de
la population donc on est très très loin
du compte
et il ya quand même un manque de
transparence sur cette mise à
disposition des vaccins tant au niveau
de l'europe qu'au niveau de la france il
est impossible de connaître les
quantités qui nous parviennent
régulièrement et c'est un vrai problème
en matière de transparence et de
démocratie y compris vous avez vu en
tant que sénateur j'imagine que vous
l'avez maintes fois demandé à l'instar
de patrick anr ya pas de réponse on vous
donne pas de réponses précises sur les
stocks disponibles et les commandes sur
qui devrait arriver non on a vraiment je
le suis depuis le début de cette
pandémie depuis le début de la campagne
de vaccination
on n'a aucune information sur les bords
au niveau de l'europe les commandes
comment elles ont été passées certains
documents sont sortis dont on a vu
qu'ils étaient raturé à certains
endroits on n'a pas les informations sur
les quantités sur les prix et c'est
valable également en france donc
l'inquiétude grandit chez nos
concitoyens tout le monde constate sur
le terrain qu'il est difficile de se
faire vacciner ici et là les délais sont
très longs et les vaccins arrivent au
compte-gouttes donc vraiment on n'est
pas à la hauteur quand je vois ce qui se
passe au royaume uni de l'autre côté de
la manche en face de chez nous faudra
qu'ils ont passé hier le stade de 18
millions de vaccinations
mais on a montré effectivement dans le
journal précédent plus de trente mille
nouveaux cas positifs
hier pourtant emmanuel macron lui
réfléchir à des solutions pour ne pas
confiné et ça passerait par le passeport
vaccinale ou le qr code est ce que c'est
un risque pour les libertés
individuelles selon vous
ça plaît mais là l'urgence franchement
l'urgence et de d'avancer de manière
décisive dans la vaccination qu'après il
faille prendre certaines mesures pour
vérifier que les gens effectivement son
protégé l'upa contaminants on peut
l'imaginer mais c'est vraiment l'urgence
la de mettre le paquet sur les
vaccinations en mettant tous les moyens
en oeuvre
votre revers au royaume uni au royaume
uni ils ont mis en oeuvre l'armée qui
est capable d'organiser la logistique
c'est son métier
et donc pourquoi on n'imagine pas de
mettre en oeuvre les mêmes dispositions
chez nous parce que pour vous c'est une
question de logistique également la
logistique les collectivités ça a été
rappelé hier lors de la réunion les les
communes les intercommunalités sont
prêtes à et au l'ont déjà fait à mettre
à disposition des locaux des personnels
des moyens humains mobiliser les
personnels soignants capable de la
d'inoculer ce vaccin mais on n'a pas des
12 il faut il faut les avoir dix diables
le mur gens c'est celle là
les médecins généralistes et les
médecins du travail peuvent vacciner à
partir d'aujourd'hui on l'a vu ça reste
assez marginale
ils n'auront que dix doses en moyenne
par semaine votre commentaire pas pareil
on est loin du compte je pense qu'on ne
parle de 30 mille médecins 10 doses par
semaine
voyez ce que ça donne comme possibilités
de couverture de la population on est on
est plus de 60 millions d'habitants
ça va encore traîner et les d échéance
annoncée pour l'été
j'ai l'impression qu'à ce rythme là ne
seront jamais atteinte elle beaucoup
d'organisations internationales
dénoncent également le fait que les pays
riches passent des commandes au
détriment des pays pauvres
après l'appel de l'onu à faire du vaccin
bien pour l'humanité
voyez d'abord ce coup de gueule du
directeur santé de la croix rouge
il est immoral d'avoir des centaines de
milliers de doses de vaccin sûr et
efficace qui reste inutilisée dans les
pays européens alors que de nombreux
membres du personnel de santé dans les
pays en voie de développement
n'obtiennent aucun vaccin
c'est non seulement immoral mais aussi à
tristan parce que toute dose du vaccin
qui n'est pas injecté dans le bras d'un
patient est égale à une mort éventuelle
du coc vite 19
le parti communiste français lui aussi
s'est mobilisé avec pour slogan pas de
profit sur la pandémie
qu'est ce que vous en dites absolument
c'est une proposition dont la formule et
ya plusieurs semaines
lever les droits sur les brevets
la licence publique moi je me suis bien
que dans les années 60 le biologiste
américain qui a découvert le vaccin
comme dans l'âtre autres la poliomyélite
l'avait dispensé de tout brevet on avait
fait un bien public
aujourd'hui on à éradiquer cette maladie
il faudrait agir de même mais bien
évidemment et des enjeux financiers
économiques très fort le le pharma
business entre guillemets voix des
profits soutien arrivé et il ya une
compétition entre les groupes
pharmaceutiques
alors on a un enjeu de santé mondiale
c'est absolument indécent et
inacceptable oui il faudrait lever les
mauvais sur cd est sûr c est sur ces
vaccins enfin pour l'élever il faudrait
une volonté de ces groupes privés il n'y
a pas de possibilité en tout cas des
contre ordres
écoutez si tous les états du monde s'y
met ce sont quand même des groupes qui
ont perçu de l'argent des centaines de
millions d'euros pour financer la
recherche
c'est le cas de sanofi par exemple mais
s'il en est c'est vrai également
ailleurs en europe c'est quand même le
politique qui doit décider quand il
s'agit de l'intérêt général et là on est
en face d'un cas d'urgence
le président va kron avait dit l'an
dernier que c'était la guerre est bien
connu à la guerre ils font tous
mobilisés et tous réquisitionnés quand
c'est nécessaire quand il est bas de la
santé des humains
j'aimerais avoir votre réaction à
présent sur ce défi lancé par emmanuel
macron à 2 youtube heures connu des
jeunes ils ont remporté et sont donc
maintenant éviter à l'elysée pour un
concours d'anecdotes regarder le
programme
bon bah on va faire un feat avec le
président on va faire les choses bien
le fit avec le président sera un
concours d'anecdotes
avec à la clé comme habituellement des
séquences de moqueries légère de rentrer
dedans de chambrage et cerise sur le
gâteau un gage pour le perdant je sais
pas si vous avez suivi cette affaire
mais que pensez vous de cet exercice de
communication est ce que c'est c'est le
rôle d'un chef de l'état moi je dis
clairement non écoutez on vient
d'évoquer les enjeux sérieux grave
urgent il ya autre chose à faire que ça
on est tombé dans le politique spectacle
depuis très longtemps mais là on tombe
dans la politique gadget c'est pas du
niveau d'une présidence de la république
très sincèrement il ya d'autres enjeux
d'autres chats à fouetter et d'autres
urgences à traiter
alors le message évidemment il est à
destination des jeunes éric bocquet les
jeunes c'est un
un exercice à visée électorale
évidemment non c'est évident mais je
pense je sais pas ce qu'on pense les
étudiants qui sont de très grandes
difficultés qui font la queue
aujourd'hui pour s'alimenter qui sont
les oubliés de ce quoi qu'il en coûte
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on va les
suivre cette manière il faut redonner de
l'espoir de l'espérance et un avenir à
cette jeunesse à cette société qui est
dominé par l'argent dans tous les
domaines on voit y compris en matière de
santé avec ses commerces et vaccins
voilà l'enjeu il est là c'est pas des
gadgets qui redonneront de l'espoir à la
population
merci beaucoup à reebok et d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france